a client bottle is a cool mathematical
shape it's an example of a
non-orientable surface so if you were
standing on it and tried to walk all the
way around back to where you started you
get there but you'd be standing upside
down it also has no boundaries and is
only one sided which is pretty cool not
many shapes have only one side a true
Klein bottle however would require four
dimensions to exist because it has to
pass through itself without a hole but
you can knit every presentation in 3d
I've made this one earlier and I'll show
you how I made it it's actually just one
piece of knitting so the outside goes
through becomes the inside which then
connects back to itself through this
little hole here and then continues
around I'll show you all the steps you
need to make one but I'll also post some
links to more in-depth tutorials on each
new stitch technique because I might go
through them relatively fast I'd say if
you're a total beginner and have never
knitted anything you could almost set
aside a whole day to make this but of
course a lot less time if you're a pro
okay so this is what you'll need some
wool for double pointed needles mine are
five point five millimeters wide and
twenty centimeters long three stitch
markers these are optional you could
also use a safety pin keyrings or just
use your math skills and count later on
you might also find it useful to have a
tapestry needle start by casting on 19
stitches this will determine the size
of the top tube you want to spread the
stitches evenly over three needles but
transfer one extra to the first needle
for the purpose of joining in the round
- joy you make a slipknot over a stitch
then transfer it back to where it came
from
watch the video in the description for
more help on this I'm inserting one of
my stitch markers to mark the end of a
round you then want to knit in the round
using a regular knit stitch until the
tube measures about 8 inches or 20
centimeters then we want to increase the
amount of stitches do this evenly by
forming six sections start by making a
stitch then knit three more place a
marker make another stitch and knit to
the end of the needle
repeat this all the way around and you
will have made six new stitches then
knit a normal round repeating the last
two steps six more times means you'll
end up with sixty stitches in total
twenty on each needle when you make
stitches do so at the start of each
section the stitch markers help to make
it even and they travel up as you knit
but you could always just count remove
the markers and insert one like safety
pin this one won't travel up as we go
knit normally in the round until the
work measures one inch or about two and
a half centimeters from the marker we'll
work a few rows back and forth to form
the side opening turn the work around
and start knitting in the opposite
direction to do this
you will need to use the purl stitch
that comes through the front work around
like this then turn back to normal and
knit back don't knit across the gap you
are trying to form repeat these two rows
once more
[Music]
then resume knitting in the round
normally until the work measures about
40 centimeters or 16 inches from the
marker less distance is required if you
are making it for a smaller head this is
the most time-consuming part of the
project to shape it down we want to
decrease our stitches back down to 18
I'll do this by forming the six sections
again at the start of each section slip
two stitches this will decrease the
total number of stitches by six every
round when you're down to 18 in total
knit three normal rounds and cast off
leave a longer tail than I did here
because we will use it to sew the Hat
together I've got a tapestry needle you
could also try to do this using a bobby
pin no something else
push the long tube through the opening
until it meets the short tube and stitch
them together fasten it any way you like
[Music]
a bit of rearrangement and your client
bottle is complete leave me a comment if
you decide to try it out or if you get
stuck best of luck with your
mathematical creations